jay query es la librería más popular en
la web hoy en día es una librería con
funciones de javascript que hace que
para los desarrolladores de páginas web
sea fácil hacer tareas comunes como
manipular páginas web responder a
eventos de usuarios obtener datos de sus
servidores crear efectos y animaciones y
mucho más
jake query se basa en la máxima
funcionalidad que nos dan los
navegadores por medio de la app y del
don de javascript pero nos permite
lograr las mismas cosas en menos líneas
de código por ejemplo digamos que
queremos cambiar el tamaño de todas las
imágenes de nuestra página como cuando
el usuario presiona un botón podrías
escribir estas cuatro líneas de código
que están aquí y funcionarían o podrías
escribir esta simple línea de código y
jay ward y haría todo el trabajo pesado
por ti
además jay query cuida cualquier error o
inconsistencia del navegador
en 2014 más del 60% de las millones de
páginas web incluyeron jay query así que
prácticamente todos los desarrolladores
web conocen jake berry o han usado jake
berry en algún punto de su carrera y
ahora tú puedes ser uno de esos
desarrolladores